II want rope with Collider and we're
with me is director Mike Doherty for
Godzilla king of the monsters how are
you doing today sir not too bad how
about you I'm doing excellent I first
want to start on cameras I've said
repeatedly on Twitter
I loved your movie now thanks it is it's
all it's awesome I recommend everyone
watching this right now to go out and
see this movie on the biggest screen you
can best sound system you will have an
amazing time and we're out that's all I
got no but being serious I actually want
to jump backwards and because you you've
directed other features but this is your
first time helming one of these massive
spectacle films so talk a little bit
about that initial meeting you went in
on who did you first sit down with to
sort of get the project can you talk
about that those moments yeah I mean it
was a it was a dinner with Alex Garcia
he's the exec over at legendary Alex and
I go way back he produced trick-or-treat
and Krampus so we've known each other of
a very long time good friends and it was
really just sort of a general ketchup
dinner or at least so I thought because
then towards the end he mentioned that
Gareth wasn't gonna be coming back for
Godzilla too and started to go in -
would you be interested and I think I
said yes before he even finished asking
sort of like I was like assuming that he
was going to be proposing and it felt
like you know a childhood birthday wish
come true I've always wanted to make a
Godzilla film my first attempt at making
a Godzilla film was when I was around 10
years old I took my family Betamax
camcorder that's how old I am and set it
up and let my pet box tortoise sort of
rampage through my Star Wars toys and
Hot Wheels toys I would do that or I'd
use my Shogun warrior Godzilla and make
like really crude stop-motion movies so
it's always been there and it's just
snowballed from there it was a three and
a half year journey to get this to
completion
I am so you're in that moment you're
you're talking to him he so he offers
you or his asked if you're interested
where does it go from there in terms of
okay so now you go home and now your
start
think about ideas yeah and so I'm
curious from that point what happens
next uh I went home and I just started
brainstorming it just it just jumped
started so many different childhood
dreams and wish lists that it I went
crazy I started watching the old movies
just sort of reigniting that that
passion and all the ideas I sort of been
storing up in my subconscious mind about
what I would want to see in a Godzilla
film and I sort of wrote up the page and
a half long very rough beat sheet slash
treatment and I shared that with a
legendary group and that got a big fat
seal of approval and from there we went
and did a writers room my writing
partner Zack shields and I ran a writers
room of like I think 10 to 12 writers
for about ten days and just started
bouncing things around again revisiting
some of the old movies it was like
throwing a Godzilla party that has been
raging ever since well I actually
specifically wanted to ask you about the
the group writers room that's been
happening on a lot of movies recently
and I'm curious how do you how does that
typically work and do you find a room
like that to be I mean like do you view
that room as being you know one of the
reasons why the film is so successful or
was it just a good way of brainstorming
all these ideas if you will all the
above I loved it I had never
participated in one before
I think it's something that the film
industry has started to cribbed from the
TV side of things where it's much more
of the norm and I it's really helpful
it's a great tool because you're just
getting a bunch of nerds together you
know theoretically people who are much
smarter than you are more talented than
you are and just sort of kick in things
around you know it's like forming a band
in your garage and nobody's wrong it
sort of helps you test the waters with
some concepts I mean I love
collaborating with other writers
filmmakers etc because again it's sort
of like sometimes the voice of a writing
partner or a writers room
it might have better taste than your own
internal voice you know so you can
really sort of test the waters to see
like is this idea really as cool as I
think it is or am I just blowing smoke
up my own ass but it's also just a good
time if you put the right crew together
it's just a really fun time and by the
end we had such a strong bond and I
really just clicked with each other and
I I think it was instrumental in getting
this film to where it needed to be
well obviously Warner Brothers and
they've already shot the next one mm-hmm
so I'm curious how much from that
writers room that day has been turned
into what we're getting now and how much
was it sort of just planting you know
what I mean uh it's all there I honestly
you know like we had such a strong room
that it it really helped shape the
general plotline who the characters were
it was just invaluable yeah sure
when the obviously there's a lot of
there's monsters to choose from there's
Titan I jus talked a little bit about
how you determined what you wanted in
this film and how maybe what came close
to making it in the film I when I came
on board legendary had already done the
hard work of securing the rights for
Mothra Rodin and King Ghidorah they did
that shortly after the success of the
2014 film you know because they were
planning this monster verse way back
when and I think they had the smarts to
know that those three creatures were
sort of the all-stars of the crown
jewels to license from Toho because I
mean let's face it like those are the
you know they are the all-stars they
were the first kaiju team-up that we saw
back in the 60s like they were the
Avengers of the Godzilla universe back
then and I they asked it wasn't a
mandate by any means they asked would
you be interested and using these
creatures for the next one and it's like
of course that's just a no-brainer
that's an easy yes Mothra was daunting I
have to admit there was a minute where I
wasn't sure if there was a cool way to
do Mothra because it's a giant moth
but what I did was I went back and
looked at all the giant insect movies
that we had seen you're going back like
tarantula from the 50s the or most
recently Starship Troopers and I
realized there's an opportunity in
Mothra because she brings such a
different vibe you know there's
something truly benevolent and beautiful
and comforting about her but she could
throw down when she needs to so it was
fun to sort of explore her more as an
approach or more as a deity you know
almost more of like a spiritual presence
in the film versus your straight-up
typical giant monster
so as challenging as each of the
creatures were there was an opportunity
in each one to so yeah it's great
the monster battles in this film are
spectacular how early on are you
designing those set pieces and just talk
a little bit about how those things come
together and and when they first started
being designed I mean quite a few of
them were part of my initial treatment
you know like when you're familiar
enough with the creatures I mean I had
always fantasized about the idea of road
day and emerging from a volcano like I
always always heartbroken by the end of
the original road and movie from 56
where both Road Ann's Parrish you know
such a bittersweet romantic ending of a
coupling of monsters who were just
attempting to mate and build a nest and
build a life for themselves burn to
death in a volcano like a monster kaiju
Romeo and Juliet story so in my mind
like how great would it have been if
that if that Rodin couple had laid an
egg in a volcano and after thousands of
years had finally come to life and their
offspring was just sort of just dating
in the volcano and so I knew that was a
no-brainer I loved the idea of having a
monster fight in Antarctica you know and
that goes back to beasts from 20,000
fathoms where they first discover the
creature in the Arctic there's something
about discovering a giant monster in an
icy Tundra kind of environment and
having a fight that's not in a city
where it typically is there something
very primal about
and you know I really just started with
each of the monsters and try to come up
with an environment that I thought
reflected the creatures you know Mothra
has always been sort of a benevolent
protector of life and nature and in many
of the past films she hatches in some
sort of ancient temple or ruins
surrounded by perverse worshippers and
whatnot so it made sense to sort of give
her a sequence in a rain forest full of
mystery and beauty and nature and so
crafting sequences that reflected the
personalities and histories of each
monster you know
Antarctica is very desolate and cold
that definitely reflects who King
Ghidorah is Rodin being born from a
volcano somewhere tropical something
that sort of felt like you know the
ancient primal world made sense so it
was more than just sort of coming up
with a giant monster and having them
attack a city it was really about
stepping back and looking at that
monsters history over the course of all
the films and trying to come up with
sequences that truly captured the spirit
of what those creatures were and would
allow them sort of flex their muscles in
a way that that really amplified what
those creatures are like giving Rodin an
aerial battle where he just tears the
crap out of a fleet of jets definite tip
of the hat to the 56 film you know where
they had that and it was just a Rodin
puppet going after miniature Japanese
Air Force jets but there was something
to the core of that idea that stuck so
deeply in my childhood mind well one of
the things about one of the reasons the
trailers for the film have gotten better
and better as the movies gotten closer
to release is because you have final VFX
shots mhm
I'm curious the look of the film and the
VFX
like the Viet I've gone on off the way
I've phrased this question is is
terrible but the VFX with the monsters
is fantastic thanks and it obviously
these are CGI creatures if you will and
you know they're all real represent
practical yeah that's our secret right
exactly yeah the thing is like you they
look incredible and it looks like these
things are there so talk a little bit of
working with the VFX houses and which
what was the toughest thing if you will
of making these creatures look
like they're actually there on screen
and getting it right I mean it's a
process it's a really long process but
thankfully I had such an insanely
talented group of collaborators from you
know my DP Larry sure my the effects
supervisor Guillaume Scott Chambliss the
production designer it was just an
all-star team of people who you know we
set off on a mission and and had a very
particular look in mind thankfully we
had the 2014 film and Skull Island to
build off of because I thought Jordan
and Gareth respectively did such a
phenomenal job at depicting their
monsters and I think Gareth really laid
the groundwork with the 2014 film you
know as much as people criticize it for
not seeing enough of the monsters I like
the Slover and approach I wish more
tentpoles embrace that slow burn but you
can't dismiss the sense of scale that he
brought to the creatures and the way
they moved where they felt like living
breathing animals that had their own
sort of internal thought process going
on and then you know Jordan really built
off that you know the way he depicted
Kong but also brought in more color and
vibrancy so I wanted to push that even
further like take what worked from those
two films and push it even further and
push it into this sort of like biblical
realm
you know our mantra on the film a lot of
times was to put the God back in
Godzilla you know to really depict these
things as ancient primal deities so that
they weren't just big monsters
destroying cities that we felt like we
were opening up the book of Revelation
and if we wanted to embrace the
mythology that these creatures were
worshipped by some previous ancient
civilization then really depict them
that way to pick them as something that
would make you drop to your knees if you
looked up on the skies and saw them so
that really involves you know pushing
the lighting the atmospherics trying to
come up with ways of the creatures would
affect their environment both directly
and indirectly using bioluminescence
depicting Ghidorah as a creature that
was capable of causing massive super
storms
you know versus just being a dragging us
out there in the open you know he's got
bioelectricity as part of his DNA so
theoretically he would cause cloud
formations he would be able to trigger
hurricane-force winds your Dan can swoop
over a city and level it without even
trying you know so these go above just
monsters destroying infrastructure the
thing about it is with these kind of
deities you can only you can do anything
so what was the stuff in that original
you set down you're doing your little
pitch you know you're the page and a
half if you will did you have anything
back then that ended up in the finished
film in terms of some of the action or
what you wanted to see hell of it oh so
it's all right yeah it's all there you
know like they you know discovering moth
or zag in a mysterious temple in a
rainforest volcano a road and emerging
from the volcano and taking out a fleet
of jets
it was all there yeah it very very
simple broad strokes but the that the
the vital first sparks were there I
believe you said that you had a much
longer first cut you always have much
longer firstly every film has that I
believe if I miss I could be wrong but I
think that you said that you had a cut
that was like 240 where my real
director's cut was around 240 245 right
again even directors cuts always run
long under absolutely but I'm curious
what were some of the last things you
took out of the film that came you know
this close to making it uh well even
with the the the extra-long director's
cut or as I called it Godzilla the
miniseries
I there weren't a lot of whole scenes
that got lifted out there are a few when
they'll end up on the blu-ray and home
video version but a lot of it was
trimming moments within each scene sure
like you'd be shocked at how much you
can streamline a film just by dropping a
line here word there you know we had a
large ensemble cast so there was a
tendency to give each character a moment
to voice an opinion in a given scene
because in it like a Godzilla movie
there's always the moments between the
fights were ever
was going what the hell do we do now
what just happened what are we gonna do
now
and so there was a tendency to give each
character a moment to express their
opinion chime in ask a question and that
adds up completely with the cast this
big and so we quickly realized okay not
everybody has to have a voice at the
round table in every scene so it was a
lot of trimming just lines of dialogue
or moments exchanges between characters
within the scene and they're so subtle
and miniscule that it's not even worth
putting them in the bonus features I
understand I should we know a lot of
filmmakers that talk about you'd be
surprised how much you can pull out when
you just trim the US or the oh yeah the
the little spaces in between the lines
yep you know yeah but talk a little bit
about balancing that because there are
you know you have these huge moments but
you also want to you want to make sure
it's not moving too fast but fast enough
so talk a little about the test
screening process and maybe what you
learned from early friends and family
screenings the most painful part of the
process probably yeah the the test
screening process is nerve-wracking I
think I still have a screen shot from my
Apple watch is what an Apple watch does
is it'll tell you if your heart rate
goes above a certain moment for a
certain amount of time really warning
you you're about to have a heart attack
right and so I'll never be saved it
because it was such a moment where like
in the first test screening I got the
alert from my Apple watch you know that
your heart rate your BPM has now been
elevated for the last 15 minutes but
it's nerve-racking because it is like
standing in front of an audience naked
and having them criticized well the
thing about this is with with this film
you have a lot of VFX yeah so how early
on in the process did you do a cut to
show to an audience early and what were
they just seeing previs or were they
seeing rudimentary CGI all of it all the
above it's a hodgepodge a mix of it
which almost makes it worse yeah when
you go from a somewhat finished shot
back to what we'd actually call post
visits a post is is where you actually
take the what you saw it on shot on a
shot on set you know in front of a green
screen and you marry it to the previous
you know so you still have your human
actors
in a scene with Godzilla but they're up
against sort of the Roger Rabbit
PlayStation 3 level graphics version of
Godzilla sure it's still better than
nothing it's better than just you know
your actors staring at a tennis ball on
a stick but it's still nerve-racking
because you don't know how much your
audience can genuinely fill in what's
supposed to be there you're still
showing an unfinished version of the
movie
with previous post biz and sometimes
even storyboard frames stuck in there
and I know that I even as a filmmaker if
I go in and watch a rough cut of a
friend's movie and there's post BISM
previz even I have trouble filling in
those blanks sometimes so maybe other
people are better at it but it's it's
nerve-racking because it's hard to sort
a gas or second guess how much your
audience is really in the flow of the
story when you're being pulled in and
out of finished shots and unfinished
shots yeah I think I've been in the same
boat of what you're talking about and I
think all you can do in that moment is
say does the story work like that's
that's really ideally yes like but the
story often whether not the story works
can depend on what you're looking at and
hearing oh no yeah absolutely so you
you're doing that early early version
yeah how talked about how many test
screenings you did over the process and
and did they impact the finished film in
terms of making changes because enough
audiences we're saying we don't agree
with this character or this character
needs to be in the movie a little bit
more we had too many test screenings
just half joking but what you learn the
funny thing is I used to run test
screenings when I was in college so I
used to work for a subcontractor of NRG
Wow and so I knew how the sausages were
made I knew how painful it could be and
I know how they tally at the cards and
all the questions they asked and so I
was least somewhat prepared and
obviously I've done a couple films but
this was definitely the most on a test
screenings I had to go through and
they're actually really really helpful
because thankfully for us and no lie
every test screening went really well
you know even if it's even in its
roughest State
they went really well and you know
different people would have different
nitpicks about Oh too many jokes from
this character that character felt like
it slowed down too much in this section
and you don't use it you don't use the
opinions from the test screening as the
end-all be-all good or bad right you
even if you have a good test screening
you don't want to go okay call it a day
that's a lock we're done you can always
make it better and so you just sort of
if you smartly use test greetings you
just use it as sort of helpful guide
objective eyes you know staying
objective is one of the hardest parts of
directing a movie you're so close to it
of course you love your characters
you've been spending a year with them
you've watched them change and every
through every step of the process but a
person who comes in and watches a
completely fresh and has never seen it
will have a very different experience so
you have to be humble enough to listen
and be open and whether that's coming
from your your your test audiences or
your executives or even your friends and
family who are watching it you have to
remain open-minded the other thing I've
spoken to a lot of a lot of directors
have told me in the test screening
process
they've been with the film for so long
that they start thinking about cutting
really funny jokes because it doesn't
work for them and you are so you need to
be reminded yeah these things are still
working yeah and we had instances like
that where it's like you get tired of
this joke or that joke or you don't
think that jump-scare is working or you
don't think that that action sequence is
working and then lo and behold you show
it to a test audience and they're
laughing they're clapping they're
cheering and suddenly it can be very
reassuring and comforting to hear very
vocal positive reactions and that that
tend to be the case with us that every
step of the way every test subsequent
tests greeting got better and better I
want to jump backwards a little bit to
the deleted scenes you mentioned there's
a few of them for listen I know based on
Twitter when I talk about Godzilla there
is an awful lot of Godzilla fans so how
many scenes will be on the eventual
blu-ray or how many minutes of stuff if
you will you know I don't have a tally I
want to say that there's roughly six to
eight scenes like actual äj--
full scenes and they're fun they're a
fun watch I mean listen if we were doing
Godzilla the TV series they would be
perfectly great scenes but when you're
trying to make a two-hour plus movie
pacing is a very important consideration
yeah no no I was gonna say that I just
spoke to Chad for John wick three and he
said the things that he's learned it's
only his third film he said the thing
that that he oh you're always struggling
with is tone and pacing yeah yeah that
that's the one-two punch and what what I
found on this particular film was the it
was to front-loaded it was too much set
up the first act was dragging because
when you're going through the writing
process you know especially when you're
working with the studio I especially in
a genre film where there's so many
things you do need to set up to such a
strange world that you're entering
there's a tendency to over explain in
the first act
because exec a doesn't understand the
rules of well what are kaiju and where
do they come from so you find the earth
you're patting all these scenes to flesh
that out more and then lo and behold
when you get the cut in you realize okay
we're over explaining the audience gets
it we can we can take the scene and
truncate it down to from three pages to
half a page one of the things there's
always merchandised for movies like this
stand well there is right exactly and
I'm all in on Godzilla merchandise my
question is what what did you what did
you take home from set and what is the
merchandise that's about to be released
or out now that you're like I need that
I need that and I need that so much
didn't get a lot from set now the honest
huge mistake go on I didn't get a lot
[Laughter]
you might have stuff but didn't actually
get anything I didn't get much right
exactly okay and I one of my it's such a
tiny token but I was fascinated by this
particular prop because you know we're
dealing with monarch which supposed to
be a top
secret organization that hunts mice ters
but they've decided that their logo is
so cool that they're gonna slap it on
mugs right she's a seen like where
they're in this you know the classic
Godzilla conference room strategy
meeting and they're drinking out of
monarch mugs and I left in the movie I
thought it was so hilarious that
somewhere within this top-secret monster
hunting organization that you know there
were emails were like okay Serizawa what
do you think about the logo placement on
the mug here you know it'd be like
having area 51 mugs completely you know
what I mean so I have a monarch mug and
it's one of my favorite mugs drink my
morning coffee out of but the merch is
nuts
I mean Touhou and Warner's and legendary
are going crazy with the Godzilla
merchandise right now and the figures
are definitely probably my favorite
because that that helped kickstart my
love of the character it was my my
shogun warriors godzilla which i still
have in my bedroom and his it's been
part of my life since 1978 you know it's
been sort of my century against the
monsters under the bed the monsters in
the closet what-have-you so to know that
there's a new generation of kids who are
gonna get these much more detailed and
articulate godzilla toys makes me really
happy and they also have like these
little tiny deformed godzilla figures i
think are more for the japanese audience
but I'm making sure I get my hands on a
set I want one of every single toy by
the way that's the right I think Mark
Hamill had that on Return of the Jedi
that might be where I heard about it
yeah the rumor is that I asked him about
this in a junket in Ohio was that I
think he redid his contract and he
wanted one of everything yeah like by
the way get to everything and then you
have one to open up play with and
display and then one to keep him storage
as you know an investment for the future
completely yeah
Guillermo when he does his movies hmm he
will when he designed something like
iMac it he will always make sure to get
to so you can keep one yeah it's
actually in my contract that I get at
least one creature maquette of each
creature
oh okay so yeah I might have been
inspired by that actually because it's
one of those ask that the studios just
don't care they're like sure whatever
nerd yeah we'll give you a key prop
right you know from and I haven't
executed that I haven't asked for it
yeah but I need to yeah it's it's
interesting that because Thomas told
when he ran legendary was also a massive
collector yeah so apparently when they
were doing pack rim or any of those
anything that Thomas and Guillermo
worked on together they each wanted one
oh yeah they would make three so
production Guillermo Thomas that
explains why there's so many Pacific Rim
props around the legendary office which
makes it cool that you walk in the
legendary office and it feels like
you're working at monarch or you know
something or you know something to do at
a giant monster lab because there's like
random creature part sort of scattered
around in different corners this leads
me to my next thing which is what did
the chin if assuming big hit
Godzilla Kong big hit what will it take
to get a Godzilla Kong pack rim in a
multi universe battle you I have no idea
just I mean that is a that is a question
for the legendary brass but yeah that's
above my pay grade my last thing for you
the at the very beginning I mentioned
how you had you haven't really made a
movie on this scale and what was the
what did you take away from the process
in terms of managing a scale scope and a
budget like this it was there anything
that maybe surprised you about the
process or you know for people that are
other filmmakers that are like you that
have worked with lower budgeted stuff
jumping to this thing like what's the
advice you can share even yeah um yeah I
finally has some distance to think about
this because it's a question that keeps
coming up and the thing is like whether
it's a small movie or a big one I go
through the same emotional rollercoaster
you know all the fear the confidence the
excitement the utter depression it's the
same right it's just because I think
when you truly care about what you're
working on and you're passionate about
it you're always gonna feel that sort of
range of emotions for better or worse i
but with bigger one the thing that I
definitely learned was how to let go
funny enough when you're surrounded by
so many amazing collaborators people who
have made a lot more movies than you
have whether it's your production
designer your DP or your editors and
when you do have more time and resources
to experiment try things go down paths
that you think will never work or sound
insane
I learned a sort of a more Zen approach
of let go let's try it why not you know
that we've got the time we've got the
money and resources to go down a path we
don't think is really gonna work really
I don't think it's gonna work
necessarily but command-z
you can always hit undo sure you know
and so I really enjoyed sort of varying
between when to hold on tight to the
wheel and when to let go and see where
things take you and I often found that a
lot of times when you do let go not only
is it a little more relaxing a little
bit but some really wonderful new ideas
can come out of that I could ask you a
million other things but you have come
back yeah I was gonna say I'm just
really mean it sincerely Congrats on the
movie thank you and for everybody
watching this thing I really mean it go
see this in the biggest movie theater
you can it's playing for at least a week
in IMAX I hope so yes and so look I
don't know what the IMAX release is but
this is one of those movies you want to
see in IMAX
wish you nothing but the best thank you
so much for coming in thank you everyone
go see Godzilla king of the monsters